Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday morning
podcast. And I am just checking in on you.
Okay. This is a very somber podcast.
I'm fucking you. It's not somber.
I just have to go do a show and I don't
wanna fuck up my voice before I even go
out there screaming like an idiot.
Um, I am in clear Lake Iowa right now.
I'm about to do the surf ball room,
the site of the,
the final buddy Holly big Bopper,
uh,
Richie valance shell.
I just landed in the airport that
they took off from there. Uh,
subsequently died.
I don't know if you heard about that.
They died along with some music I believe.
And um,
yeah, I told a lot of people that was
flying into there. It was like, dude,
what are you Outta your mind?
Well, good luck dude. Good
luck. You know what I mean?
You, they don't say that when
you fly out of lax. Right.
Some fucking more on, flew his plane
into a commercial airliner at Elliot,
you know, when the guy
was on finals. So, I mean,
I don't understand what the deal is.
The reason why they are plane crashes
because they didn't have the technology
back then. There was a, they
had ice on the wing. Okay.
Not only adding weight to the aircraft,
it changes the shape of the fucking wing
so it doesn't produce the lift you need.
And then you got the big bopper in
there. But he's a big guy, a Da.
You got yourself a problem. All
right? No, we all know that.
I've been off the booze, I've been
losing weight. So I'm flying in,
I'm not flying in,
I'm riding in and I'm in a prop
plane coming down from Minneapolis.
And of course, you know, when
you're flying commercial,
you look at a prop plane like, dude,
what the fuck? You know? But uh,
if you just knew how much
the plane probably costs,
I don't know. Probably too,
it's probably a $2 million plane.
Okay.
All right. They can seat 10 people.
Now if you just look at that,
like what if I owned that? What
if I own one of those? I have,
if you had a 10 passenger fucking plane,
you are the shit.
Everybody's like this guy, he's dude,
he's to fucking play. He's got a plane.
What does it hold? 10 people get the
fuck out of you. That guy's crushing it.
But the second you fly
commercial and it's a 10 seater,
everybody gets all fucking freaked out.
Like I'm not getting
in that piece of shit.
The exact same plane that if your buddy
down the street went and bought it, you,
you,
you would think that he hit the lottery.
Okay.
All right.
A lot less mute moving fucking parts.
So I get on the thing and I immediately
texted a buddy of mine who's fucking
terrified of flying just
to watch. You know, I was,
I really wished that he was there,
a buddy of mine outside of comedy.
So I'm taking the picture as the lady
who's going to fly it is doing the, uh,
the announcements, telling us basically
what not to do. And uh, he goes,
dude, there's no fucking way
I would be on that plane.
And then he saw the woman's face. He
goes, is that the pilot? And I go, yeah.
And he goes, no, no way.
He said,
not for females.
Fucking unbelievable.
What do you mean not for females?
And she doesn't have to bench press it.
It's a fucking machine. Jesus Christ.
And because of guys like you,
she probably went to extra
bullshit to become a pilot.
I think she's going to be fun.
She crushed it. Of course.
Not for females. Um, I dunno.
I'm sure some women will
be offended by that,
but it really just had to do with
this person's fear of flying.
You know what I mean? He wants, you
know, he basically wants to pilot that.
I don't know what to look like to look
like fucking Lee majors of some shit. Um,
and to be honest with you,
most of them don't because they set up
in an uncomfortable chair their whole
life and they got a quick turn around.
So they run in the eat airport food and
a lot of them, the lot of them look like,
you know, if they didn't have like
that, uh, it actually, you know what,
if you went to a buffalo wild wings
and you took the average football fan,
you know, draft kings,
fucking Jalapeno poppers,
fucking loud moron and you took that
fat fucks Jersey off and you put on a
pilot, you put them in a pilot uniform
and he told you flew for America and you'd
believe it.
You know,
not saying that the average pilot is as
dumb as the average dope that goes to a
fucking sports bar,
myself included.
I'm saying that they have the same
body type. That's all I'm saying.
All right. So anyways, you know, one
thing that was fucked up is that, um,
I guess it's probably a numbers thing.
There was only 10 of us,
including the pilot and it was one
of those flights where, you know,
they got to like weigh your bags, all of
that shit. They tell you where to sit,
you know,
the whole weight and balance thing.
And then one of the passengers
gets to sit up in the copilot seat.
And I was just thinking like,
that's the only part about this that I
don't like that there's only one pilot
here. Uh, you know,
flying commercial and it should be two
people in case somebody has some sort of
cardiac episode or a or whatever.
Right.
That was the only thing I was
concerned about, but it was a course.
It was a cloudy day and all that
shit. Um, but, uh, it was incredible.
So anyways,
um,
I think I might do this podcast in
two parts because I'm so excited to be
playing this venue here tonight. I'm
here with Dean del Ray were freaking out.
They were going to get to play this
place and it's still the original stage.
Uh,
most of these places,
they don't have the original stage
because whoever was legendary who played
there didn't immediately go out,
get on a plane, and then died.
So immediately that place became
like this shrine. So they,
they've added to the stage, but the
wood flooring is the same. And like,
we're going to stand on
the same fucking word.
I don't know if you're into that type
of stuff. Um, I am. So I'm very excited.
I guess everybody's ever played there,
assigned the wall.
I'm going to try and take pictures
that they let us know. So, um,
but either way I'm to come back and,
um,
finish out this podcast after
I do the show. Um, by the way,
um, I hope you guys enjoyed that
live podcast as much as I did. Uh,
I got a bunch of compliments.
People really liked it.
I definitely want to do
another one. Um, it was weird.
I felt like I was doing standup,
but I was just sort of sitting
down on the couch and, um,
and I was also like amazed
at what people laugh at.
You know, I had, you know,
I just spent doing it,
talking to myself like
I am right now forever.
I have an idea what you laughing at,
but I had no idea how much you guys
laughed when people wrote in and shit all
over me. Um, when they,
when they ask advice and um,
and then the level of crazy shit that I
say on here, just being a fucking moron.
I had no idea that people laughed at
that. I just pictured, I always pictured,
I always picture guys snickering and
then their wives shaking their heads
walking out of the room. That's what I
picture when people listen to my podcast.
I didn't realize, you know, we had,
we had a nice mix of people there,
although they, oh my God,
if I have to tell you this,
there was this one group of ladies who
went to the show that were just hell bent
on, let me know that their friend
didn't laughed once. Right?
Oh, how did I, is a great story. So I'm
standing there and taking pictures, right?
Fucking, uh, you know,
signing in the posters and all that
shit for everybody who came out to the
podcast. I'll be in a great guy. I'm
a made guy and being a great guy,
I could have just done the fucking show
and I could have hidden the green room
afterwards being like, I'm
too tired. I don't want to
meet people, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
I don't want to do it because I was in
Reno and that guy reached in for is a
camera that time and the loaded glock
fell on the floor that he said, oh shit.
Quickly picked up and ran out
of the fucking place. I did.
I walked out there and I was being
a good guy. Right. So these, uh,
these older ladies, right.
Um, all their meeting,
they're probably about a year younger
than me, a year or two younger than me.
You never know. It's very hard to guess
a woman's age or white woman's age,
you know, you can't tell.
You know what I mean?
Because they're not big on using lotion
and FTF a kid like that does something
to you, you know, see, you know,
as a guy it's hard because as
long as we take care of ourselves,
we don't have to go through giving birth.
You know what I mean?
Although we do have to live with women,
I made me,
maybe it just all kind of
washes out. I Dunno. Anyways,
I think they will roughly my age.
Um,
and also I wasn't in like a,
I was in Phoenix.
Uh, Phoenix is a, yeah,
there's enough plastic surgery there that
people give a shit what they look like.
Some of these cities should
go to like they, you know,
like do you ever like watch old movies
or old TV shows in the 70s and you'll see
somebody or you look at a picture,
what are your favorite actors
when they're 25 it's like, dude,
that guy looks like a 40 year old.
Like what 25 used to look like
compared to the way it does now? Well,
when you go to smaller towns, those
people age, the way people use to age,
like Lucille Ball going from
I love Lucy to the Lucy show.
She looked like she did it 40 years later.
She went from having this really nice
voice and be like, Ah, myth demoed a,
I like fucking smoking camel on filters.
Whatever the hell she did.
Um,
I dunno,
but anyways, what the fuck is my point
is that these ladies come walking up.
All right. I could have just said
they were about my age. Right.
Which means to fucking old.
So they would just say, hey,
you know, you said in that question
you, you, you know you wanted,
I was saying guys, you need to be
honest. And they was, I think they,
I think what happened was I think that
they didn't like what I said about the
woman that found out she was banging
this guy who had a wife and family.
I don't think that they, I don't think
they'd like the response to that.
So they came up cause they seem
like they wanted to make me upset
cause they came up and they will go
like, yeah, just to let you know,
just to let you know, she,
she didn't laugh once.
She didn't laugh once and I
laughed because that's funny,
right. I was just like,
ah, I'm sorry. Right. And she goes, yeah,
I liked you to stand up but that podcast,
live podcast, I don't know about
that. And I went like, oh all right.
And she goes, yeah, cause like I didn't
laugh once and I was like, all right.
And then they were going like,
yeah, and you said to be honest.
And she didn't laugh once. I
was just like, all right, cool.
So I mean, what do you
want me to do? I mean,
I had an hour and 20 minutes to make you
laugh. I didn't make you laugh. I mean,
I'm sure as hell not going
to do it standing there.
So I don't know what
they were looking for.
And they just kept hammering that
fucking point going, you said,
he said, you want an honest, we're just
being honest. I said, I appreciate it.
It's fine. You know? And then I
finally just said, look ladies,
like everyone else was laughing and
then I kind of made a motion around the
woman who wasn't laughing. I was like, I
can survive this. And they all went ooh.
And I was like,
I wasn't shitting on her.
I just always look at it like the
president of the United States. Okay.
Like I went in there,
there was like four or 500 people there.
One person came up and said
that they didn't like it.
So just to make round numbers,
we'll say 399 out of
400 people enjoyed it.
Okay. If a president or a senator
had that level of approval rating,
I mean it would be unheard
of on fucking heard of.
So I'm going to walk away
thinking that was a win. And um,
you know, I dunno, they just, oh,
they just kept coming over and be,
she didn't like it.
She did not like it.
And that's the greatest thing you can
ever do when anybody criticized you,
just be like,
hi.
Okay,
no wait. I want you to feel
the weight of me not liking it.
Um, I should have asked,
just giving her a refund.
Why would you pay for the ticket
sweetheart? All right. Tell you what,
I'll make a deal.
I will give you that money
back and whatever else it
takes to get these fucking
hands away from me. Good Lord.
I'll, I was trying to think,
what did I say that made
them take it to that level?
Because there's no way if they were with
some guys, I would think, all right.
They got dragged to the show and they
were like, who is this fucking animal now?
That's happened to me a million times.
And then I sheepishly apologizing.
It's like, sorry, I'm a moron. Um,
but they came there by themselves,
which means they liked me
before they went there.
So either she truly,
yeah,
didn't laugh once,
truly did not like it because she just
didn't think I was funny or somewhere in
there. I pissed her off. I think
it might've been that, you know,
I'm going to say, uh, it was
either the married woman thing,
the ovarian cancer,
the dead first wives
in the snow and Aspen,
I'm going to say somewhere in there,
she decided that she needed to tell me
that she didn't last once. Didn't
laugh once. I have to do tell you,
it kind of made my fucking night though.
Um,
every once, and I can't say
every once in a while. Well,
it is every once in a while now because
I don't go out there, but man, I, oh, oh,
okay.
Oh God. I had some fucking,
I can't, I'm so old.
I can't even remember the
amount of fucking times.
Especially a lot of women too cause
I went to a bad period but a good,
I dunno,
I'd say like 12 year period out of my
25 just really trash and women and that
just really was just my fucking issues.
Um,
I'm trying to think what the fuck.
I didn't vaguely remember
being in North Carolina
and this woman was walking up to the
table and it was fucking hilarious or
boyfriend or husband was like
holding her back. He lived,
he was water skiing behind her.
She was drunk or whatever.
I can't remember what the fuck she was
saying cause it was such a spectacle
watching that guy trying to hold her
back and she was like climbing forward.
Okay.
It, you know what it looked
like. It looked like, you know,
like wartime footage when
they like split up families.
It looked like she was trying to
get back to her child. Like, that's,
that was the level of effort that she
was making just to come up to me to tell
me how much of a fucking
moron moron she thought I was.
And, uh, that was a good
night's comedy club.
I do remember that. I just don't
remember what I said or what she said.
I had that one, this is weird. They're
all coming to their like, faceless,
like they're like, you know,
like when you watch like psycho,
when he comes in with the knife and
you can't see his face, spoiler alert,
he can't see his face. Um, that's what
they kind of looked like to me anyways.
I don't want to dwell on this
shit any longer, but, uh, anyways,
if for whatever reason,
if that woman who didn't laugh once
is still listening to this, uh,
I dunno. I Dunno what you want from
me. I would, you know something,
I would go to the all things comedy
network. We have plenty of podcast.
I'm sure there's something else that
you could find there. By the way,
the podcast network, uh, the all
things comedy podcast network, uh,
the first annual,
um,
podcast festival was a smashing success.
We got rave reviews from everybody came
out. I really want to thank everybody.
And then also Ari Shaffir who was just
sort of the mayor of the podcast festival
where he got in Thursday, he jumped
on everybody's podcast. He just,
was he just the fucking greatest guy ever.
Um,
so anyways,
with that,
how can I go this far into my podcast
and not mention the first world
championship ever by the Houston Astros?
How great is that?
That was such a great thing. That was as
great to see as it was sad for la. Yeah.
I'm telling you, you got to hate that
somebody has to lose a game seven.
It's just brutal.
I was actually sitting there thinking how
cool it would be to actually see magic
Johnson. He's got an NBA NBA ring
and a world series ring. This eight.
Does anybody a sports nerds?
Anybody know anybody out
there on both of those rinks?
I'm thinking back in the
day, maybe somebody won the
football and the baseball,
that was like a big thing for you or two
sport guy in those sports didn't really
overlap that you could
possibly win two titles. Um,
but uh, I don't know about a
fucking stomach is growling,
trying to stay in shape, but like a
three more days in this fucking movie.
So you want to fucking days. I actually,
I if she brought in a Caesar Salad,
I'm going to say that one more
time. A Caesar's salad. Okay.
And I always want to do that because I
love when people start yelling at you
about the amount of calories and the
dressing and the crew tones and Yada Yada
and all of that fucking Shit and how
you might as well have had a steak. Um,
I think all of that is bullshit
cause you still have the lettuce
with all the fucking, you know,
pesticides on it,
you know,
I mean that's a decision
you have to make right now.
Do I want to eat a cow
that ate another cow,
was with hormones in it or do I want to
eat this thing that was sprayed by DDT
or whatever the fuck is in this
shit. Um, the end of the day,
if you're gonna eat bad,
if there's a fucking salad,
I mean I'll go with the,
the cancer has pesticides as probably
worse to eat one of those things.
But I don't want to hear this shit about
the fucking dressing. I didn't want,
I didn't want to fuck, I don't
hear a word about that. Okay.
Cause I know I feel after I eat as fucking
Caesar Salad versus how I feel if I
eat a steak, you know, with a couple
of sides, the fuck Outta here.
That's it. That is it. I'm fucking
grabbing at my pants. Like Matt Foley
and I, I'm, I have a gut for
like three days after that.
Um, I know it's all fucking
bad for you. It gives a shit.
I just need to hit the elliptical.
Um,
I started my physical
therapy for my rotator cuff,
a injury finally. I don't know why it took
so long. Like how long have I do that?
Goes through these exercise three
times a day. I go, when should, when,
how long should it say skies? When I
was six weeks typical German, Irish,
stupid freckled cont I've been dealing
with this for a year and a half.
Like an asshole.
I could've just gone to somebody,
a goddamn physical therapist. This says,
yes, we deal with this all the time.
This is what works.
Do this see in a week.
So I'm very excited. My shoulder
actually feels a little bit better. Um,
although being out in this Iowa,
whether, fortunately I checked, um,
I check the weather before it came
out here, cause I wouldn't, you know,
live in La. You don't think
it's just endless summer out.
They sometimes you forget
what time of year it is.
I actually brought a peacoat out here
and I gotta tell you it's fucking killing
my shoulder to put it on and off.
Um,
had to have dean helped me put my coat
back on after we ate the worst fucking,
the worst fucking meal I've had since I
was with Dean del Rey again when I was
in Wyoming and we ate and this little
diner and I think though the short order
cook wasn't there that day and I
ordered two eggs over easy. They can't,
they were like clear.
It looked like fucking breast implants
with Yolk in the middle of it. What?
This fucking Guy Brian.
I still ate him cause I was hungry.
I remember the waitress came by, she
was just like, was, was that all right?
But I was just like,
yeah, it's fine. And um,
this time we were walking a,
I can't even tell you
the name of the airline that
we fucking took in here.
I don't even know the name of it.
It was,
it was a play on like Air Force One,
like the president.
Hang on one second. Let me see if
I can find this shit. Ah, fuck you.
Pod. All right. Hey, we go,
here we go. And if the,
what the fuck is it?
What the fuck is my, you don't
want, I didn't want us on the plane.
I deleted like a hundred fucking text
messages, you know he had that thing like,
oh my God,
I can't delete it.
If I delete it then I don't have the
thread like you're trying some case.
I just started deleting a of them, you
know, it felt good. All right, here we go.
What is the name of this fucking thing?
Air Choice One.
You know, we couldn't even
pre check in for this thing.
He had to walk to the gate. We were
in Minneapolis and it was just like,
we just kept walking.
And why don't know why we didn't
take the little monorail thing.
We just kept walking and
walking it in like concourse B,
which was like you went down some
stairs and walked underneath the fucking
tarmac or some shit.
Yeah,
take it over to this other side. And
uh, but it was still cool as shit.
And then when we landed in
like the mid city airport,
I think that's what it's called.
I don't know what the fuck it's called,
but it was a coolest Shit airport.
You just walk right in to gate agents.
This like 12 chairs down
near the baggage claims.
I love little airports. Um, anyway,
so we were, we were on our way over
there and I had the worst fucking
food that I've had since when
I was in Cheyenne, Wyoming.
And I know that place is better than what
it was. I just went there on a bad day.
I'm not shitting on Wyoming. I'm
not shitting on Cheyenne. Alright.
Um, I got the meatloaf
with the mashed potatoes.
All right. And Spinach
and a, and I went here,
we talk about red meat and
starch. Everybody knows it.
Shut the fuck up. All right.
I like potatoes with the meat.
I don't give a shit.
So they put this mushroom gravy on
top of it. I swear to God it tastes,
I don't know,
it tastes like somebody just took
an aerosol can in sprayed it.
It had like a chemical taste to it.
It was so fucking bad. I was like,
Dean tastes tastes. It seems
just, you know, just like,
what the fuck? I was like,
I know.
Then you know what fixes everything.
What is the duct tape of food?
Huh?
They give you are in construction, right?
If you have a problem Ducky, right?
You take out the duct tape,
you fucking, you know,
wrap it around a few times and you're
fine. What is the duck tape of food?
Everybody, we all know
it. We all love it. Salt,
salted the shit out of it.
Salt couldn't even help it.
I had to go for ketchup.
I had to put salt and up on this fuck,
I just finally had a tap
out. Um, and I always,
whenever the waitress comes over says,
how was the food? Even if it sucks, I say,
how are you going? He was, see, she,
I always at, I always say it was good.
It was good. Thank you. Um,
I even said it was good when I had the
breast implant fucking eggs over easy.
Right? And this was the
time I was going to be like,
if she asked me how this is,
I'm going to say this is,
I'm just going to say this tastes
like this is like, I dunno what,
like like homeless, like some
homeless guy soaked his feet in it.
Like I was actually, she's sitting
there waiting for the waitress to come
thinking, how can I accurately
describe how fucking horrific this.
And if you're in Minneapolis
in Minneapolis and you're
going to take air choice
one airlines, there's a fucking
restaurant right to the left,
right before you go down the escalators
of don't get the meatloaf with the gravy.
All right,
spoiler alert.
Okay.
Oh my God. What was it? Chemical is the
only way to describe it. It wasn't like,
what is that ingredient?
You're like truffle oil.
Truffle oil is fucking obnoxious.
It just,
it just overwhelms anything that it's on.
It's never always there.
Truffle oil in here. It's how much
truffle oil is in this fucking thing.
It's undeniable. This
taste. I, I, you know,
I wish I could've brought it to one
of those cooking shows. You know,
all those fucking guys would like a,
and when and women,
they got like those pallets
go. Okay. Okay. Um, I'm
tasting a little Oregano. Um,
uh,
there's chocolates or like those obnoxious
cigar videos with those Douche bags,
those fucking Douche bags
sit there smoking a cigar. That
is one of the most like, ah,
the morning most ignatia stinks you
will ever see put on a youtube video and
watch a guy do a review
of a fucking cigar.
I fucking hate. I hate when they see
there's Cha, I'm tasting chocolate.
It tastes like chocolate in the smoky fat.
Fuck.
What did you just go to friendlies?
You need a Jim Dandy.
Who the fuck tastes chocolate?
What do you,
you fucking smoking one of those cigars
that they have dipped in like that
sugary shit you've ever had.
Some fucking guy with his sweet
tooth gives you a goddamn cigar.
Okay.
You gotta go like the dentist
the next day. All right.
I gotta I gotta pick this up. I gotta go.
I'm actually a couple of minutes later,
I gotta go. Um, when I, when I returned,
I will tell you what it was like to
perform at the legendary surf ballroom for
me. It's going to be an hour and a half
for you. It's going to be a mere second
and a bag just like dead,
just like that. Two seconds.
So your life a good fucking uh, I
don't know what that was. Three,
four hours of my life. I just performed
at the serve ballroom, clear lake,
Iowa. Um, unbelievable.
One of the coolest and and also like
a spooky spookiest places I've ever
performed at a,
okay,
so here's the deal. You draft
your pull up, it looks like,
it looks like it's front of the 1950s
you walk in the exact same door.
They all walked in and there
was this little green room area.
It looks like they used to
be a bathroom back there too.
They kind of just got rid of that
and they had a couple of sinks,
I guess that they use to some shit.
And everybody's autograph these walls.
And I'm sure that that's,
this is like the fifth time they probably
painted over and probably paying over
like once every decade.
And they just keep like these big people,
like a Willie Nelson,
Merle haggard,
Waylon Jennings of course. And then
all these other people I saw, you know,
all the guys from like skid row,
bunch of bands that I knew from the
eighties and nineties, early nineties,
that I used to listen to faster
pussycat, all of them. Uh, who else?
Just a whole bunch of people.
So anyways,
you go out there and I'm telling
you, man, it's like this giant,
it looks like it's not a happy days.
And what they did is they had
the original stage and then, uh,
they built out from the original stage.
But some woman a number of
years ago actually had photos
from that night and she
found them all these years later. So you
can actually tell where the stage was.
So I made sure when I was up there and
I walked all the way back to what they
have,
like the phone where Richie Valens and
buddy Holly made their last phone calls.
It's really, I mean it's, it's,
it's, it's this weird thing of like,
like,
uh,
an incredible part of history
and like really morbid.
MMM.
I Dunno. And I'm always interested in that
type of shit. And then it's also weird,
like I went to Elvis's house
and I remember going in there,
I was a young comic and I wanted
to go in and laugh like, yeah,
look at his shag carpet.
What the fuck's up with Elvis?
And it went in there and I actually felt
bad after awhile. I was like, I mean,
I mean this guy's house, this is what
this guy used to chill out and shit.
I feel like,
you know,
this is a,
yeah.
You know, and then the end, you're
walking by his grave and shit. It's like,
can we just leave this guy alone already?
Cause they haven't,
they made enough fucking money.
And then you go across the street,
there's a gift shop. They literally
made a cuckoo clock, you know,
said it looked like his, his
hips will move it and shit. Um,
but the way they did it here, it
was very like respectful, but um,
it's Kinda hard to not feel like a
little bit of a ghoul when you go there.
I'm a little bit of a go. I don't, but
death is, is interesting. You know,
dead rockstars are interesting. They're
all right. And I was interested in,
I went and I got to perform
there and stand on the stage.
It was fucking amazing.
And uh, everybody coming out in the
show was fucking crowd was awesome.
I'm telling you all you fucking elitist
liberal cons, who live near an ocean,
you'd think you're fucking, I dunno
what you really missing out. All right.
And all you redneck fucking,
uh,
my pig one first fucking blue ribbon and
the fucking who gives a shit contest.
You're missing out by not
going out into the coasts.
The rights everybody fucking grow up
cause there's fun to be had out there.
You know what I mean?
MMM.
You know, it was funny when I was on
the plane ride over, this woman's going,
I was like, she's like, it's one
of the most friendliest places.
Everybody waves alone and everybody's
just really friendly out here, you know,
of course my head, I'm
thinking, yeah, if you're white,
I'm not seeing
a black guy can't come out here. But if
a certain amount came out here, you know,
and they weren't going to fucking
play for Iowa or Iowa state,
that'd be some issues. Um, you know,
it's, I don't know why, but that's the
way the world is. All right, let's, uh,
let's do a little, uh, oh yeah.
And then we came back to the hotel and
ran into this fucking guy and he came up
to me, he's going to let
people keep saying that. You
know, I look at, look like it,
I above me and he's fucking shit faced.
And I was just like,
I would take that as an insult.
I go,
you're a better looking version
of make it just, you know, big,
tall drunk guy. He just compliment
just fucking whatever he wants to hear.
Get him the fuck away from me. Right.
But he's still a funny guy and he just,
he was very like a talk
with his hands and shit.
He was just this giant 20
years younger me with hair.
And
I finally just, I couldn't
take it anymore. I finally
just said to him, I said,
dude, you're hammered. He goes,
what? I go, you're hammered.
He goes, hammered. I go,
hammered.
Cause I'm sorry.
And he walked away.
Oh, what a great, oh, what
a great bar. It was. Oh,
would I have loved to sat down and had
a couple of SAS Barilla's but I didn't.
77 days in 77, ray book 77. Paul Coffee,
77.
Nate soldier.
Okay.
Uh, 77, uh, fucking led Zeppelin tour.
All right,
let's read advertising here and then I'm
going to fucking upload this thing here.
1125 central time. All right. Dollar Shave
Club. Everybody. Dollar Shave Club here.
You've heard me talk about
the amazing shape I get.
I got from my dollar shave club razor,
especially when I use it with
their doctor. Covey's easy shave.
Well, I'm here to tell you I'm never
giving up my membership. In fact,
I'm adding even more dollar shave
club products to my daily routine.
The fuck are they talking about?
I'm too stupid to figure
out how to get a membership.
You know what I did use after tonight?
Uh,
I fucking ate some chicken wings and I
used a one wipe Charlie Cause Dean Delray
had one supposed to be for your ass,
but it works for your face to just be
sure no one used it on their ass first
year. Right? Dollar Shave
Club makes products for your
hair, face, skin, shower.
Uh, everything you need, they make
you look good and feel amazing.
And it's all their own original stuff.
They only use the finest
premium ingredients and they
deliver it right to your
fucking door just like
they do their raises.
That means no more annoying
trips to the store,
cruising up and down the aisles looking
at all this stuff from the shelf.
What the hell is this?
What do I do with this? Um,
okay.
You know, it'd be, you know,
even less annoying is less copy.
How fucking long is this. Um, okay.
You can use dollar shave club from us.
Everything. Razors, body cleansers,
Hair Gel and now's a great time to give.
Dollar Shave Club would try.
You can try your first month of their
best razor along with their travel size
versions of the fucking she
a body cleanser and yes.
Even the butt wipes just for five bucks.
Come on you cheap prick. You know better.
You look, the more likely you're going
to get fucking late right after that.
Replacement cartridges, cartridges
ship for just a few bucks a month.
It's the dollar shave club started set.
Get yours for $5
exclusively@dollarshaveclub.com
slash bar that's dollar shave
club.com/burr. Ah Right.
Okay. Oh No. These guys,
I got strict instructions not to bring
up their competition during the read.
[inaudible] lift.
Everybody lift.
I'm not talking about the 80s and just
fucking bench pressing and doing curls
and do when you try and do when your
shoulders and never doing squats.
That was the easy A's. I'm not
talking about eighties working out,
laying on a fucking tanning bed with the
little chicken wings and you're fucking
middle linebacker up a body.
I'm not talking about that with you.
Big Thick fucking aerobics socks.
Yeah.
All right, and your macgyver haircut,
you David Hasselhoff haircut.
I'm not talking about that when I'm
talking about is a ride service. Lyft, l.
Y. F. T. Lyft knows that their
drivers are what? Keep them moving.
Okay.
They do everything they can to make sure
that drivers are happy on every trip.
Lyft is the ride sharing company that
believes in treating its people better.
I believe if elected lift believes that
being there was a lot of beliefs here.
Believes in being a ride,
sharing dry, that being a ride,
sharing drivers should be fun.
If you're having a good time.
So are the passengers. Wait, don't
enjoy yourself too much then,
but he got my life in your hands.
Okay, now for the jokes, turn around.
Look at the fucking road here.
Lyft was the first to offer in ad.
Typically when you drive for Lyft,
you keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers have been paid over $200
million in tips since the feature was
introduced.
Express pay lets drivers get paid almost
instantly instead of waiting for weeks.
Lyft has even taken the
guesswork out of pickups.
The new amp device uses color coding
to help pass. Just find the drivers.
You can earn hundreds of dollars a week
plus tips one her and more money drive
more. It's never been easier to give
yourself a raise. It's a simple formula.
Happy drivers mean happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out of 10 Lyft
riders get a perfect five star rating.
Plus people usually to mean
to say that they stunk.
Kind of like how you know I was finally
going to say something about that
fucking meatloaf with
the mosquito spray on it.
So joining the ride sharing cups.
So join the ride sharing company that
believes in treating people at treating
gets people better.
Go to lift.com/bird today and you
can get a $500 new driver bonus.
That's lyft.com/burr lyft.com/burr
limited time only terms apply.
Did Tarantino, right? These,
how fucking long can these be?
Even he at least had a little overtures,
some shit in the middle, right?
Or did that begin? I Dunno. Pro Flowers.
Okay.
Do you have any of those people who are,
if you know any of those people
who were obsessed with fall,
things like pumpkin spice
lattes and scented candles.
Pro Flowers has the perfect gift.
A pistol with one bullet in it,
and I'm sorry proflowers has a perfect
gift of long lasting Bo bouquet and their
favorite fall colors there.
Bestselling cinnamon theater.
Roses are a great option for a birthday,
an anniversary or any fall occasion or
go with one of the classics like 100
autumn blooms or it doesn't autumn roses,
you can't lose because no matter
which bouquet you send my listeners,
you send my listeners,
get 20% off of any pro flowers,
unique bouquets for only $29 or more to
get 20% off all the bouquets or $20 $9 a
more. Go to proflowers.com and
use my code burr at checkout.
That's proflowers.com and code burr.
Just going to pause here cause I don't
think they ever really listened. Uh,
why would you have autumn?
This is off the record here.
If I can just speak off the record here.
Why the fuck would you have
an autumn theme with flowers?
That's when everything fucking dies,
right? It doesn't make any fucking sense.
All right?
He likes everybody Hallux.
There are a ton of online mattress
retailers popping up these days.
All with a one size fits all solution
to a better sleep. Well guess what?
One size fits all doesn't fucking work.
All right? I don't give a shit what
those other mattress companies tell you.
K He likes Helux. They know what they're
talking about. He likes sleep operas,
something that doesn't
exist anywhere else. Um,
mattress personalized to your unique
preferences and sleeping style that won't
set you back.
Thousands of dollars.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
burr where your junk fine,
which way it swings
when you go to rollover.
And they'll have a little fucking pillow
that sewn into the mattress to catch it.
Sorry.
A mattress.
Personalized your unique preferences and
sleeping style that won't set you back.
Thousands of dollars. Go
to a helix, sleep.com/burr.
Take their simple two to three minutes
sleep quiz of somebody had the right that
why don't we do a benefit
for that fucking person?
They're always talking about
people that have diseases.
What about the person has to sit down
and come up with a fucking quiz about a
mattress? There's one who went to college
for this is why I'm buried in debt.
They'll build a custom met despite people
drink, they build a custom mattress.
That will be the best thing
you've ever slept on for couples.
They even personalize
each side of the mattress,
which we all know is the beginning
of the end of the fucking.
I just feel like we're not connecting
everyone from Gq to cosmopolitan to New
York Times. We're all talking about
helix and once you try it out,
you'll know why your customer mattress
arrives direct to your door in a week and
shipping is completely free. Uh, just make
sure you're home when they deliver it,
so someone else's and sleeping on it.
In this fucking economy.
Try it for a hundred nights.
If you don't love it,
they'll pick it up and you and refund it.
They'll pick it up,
gross and refund you in full.
A CTA must read.
Oh, let's call to action in the
advertising world. Uh, go to helix,
sleep.com/burner right now and you get
$50 towards your custom mattress sets.
Heloc sleep.com/burr for $50
off your order. One more time.
Helix sleep.com/burr oh lastly,
but not leastly stamps.com and everybody,
their headliner,
they always go and last. Stay stamps.
Save you time and money. Yeah,
you don't have to walk over to somebody.
You can fucking put a piece,
a little thing on there.
And then the person with the little blue
shorts shows up and they take it, um,
which you make. Okay. Which you
can use to grow your business.
I can mail any letter,
any package using just to my computer
and my printer and mail them.
And the mail man picks it up.
The mail man picks it up, right?
Mayor Lady shows up in a little fan,
you know,
all dainty ride sidesaddle avoid,
pushing the fucking gas and the brake
with little selfie stick. Sorry,
I live in La.
That's how it's done.
Avoid the hassle of the post office man
and mail everything from postcards to
envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamp account in minutes
online with no equipment to lease and no
longterm commitments.
I use stamps.com anytime I sent on and
he may posters whenever I'm going to
whore myself out after my shows.
I am a moron if I can figure out
how to use this device. So can you,
and right now youtube,
youtube like the band can
enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus bonus.
What?
Four week trial plus postage and a digital
scale without longterm commitments.
We a go where?
No where you ever see that?
Me a Gif,
jiff whatever the fuck you call,
go to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirdthatstampsdotcomenterbursestamps.com.
Never go to the post office again.
What was that Jif?
Remember that something, uh, what you,
you know when the woman's sake,
where is this relationship going to?
And then they cut to that old p
diddy song. We a go where? No,
where we a go.
No Web.
Um, that's it. All right.
I think that's the podcast.
I had such a great time and uh,
I came in and got to meet a bunch of
people afterwards. A lot of people,
some people came in from Colorado,
people came in from all around. Um,
just to check out the venue. That's
what I liked about the show tonight.
I had a great time and I also feel there
was a bunch of people that had never
been to that venue venue before.
So they got more than a show.
They also got to see that part
of rock and roll history. Uh,
I mean in the pictures in there, the
people that have played there, it's,
it's unbelievable. Before,
you know, all of those guys,
Ritchie Valens it, all those guys
play. They're like Duke Ellington.
They have a piano that Duke Ellington
played, like sitting in the fucking lobby.
MMM.
It's incredible. And it's beautiful
out here. And, uh, and that's it.
I feel like I, I brought America
together with this show. You know,
I live out in liberal Hollywood where,
you know,
we believe and we know that we are
better than anybody else in this country
because we live near an ocean and we
make movies about social issues to show
that we care before returning
back to our gated communities,
you know, and we only wished that the rest
of the country would catch up with us.
I'm fucking with you anyways. That's
it. I'm on my way til two, uh,
Milwaukee,
Wisconsin tomorrow.
MMM.
One of my favorite fucking cities. And uh,
I'll tell you all about that on Monday.
And then I'm going up to green bay now.
I was supposed to hang around and go to
the bump up Monday night football game.
That's why we booked that one.
MMM.
But UNF, well, actually it's a good
thing. I mean, I got an acting Gig,
so I have to leave after the show to
do my last three days on a movie called
front runner starring Hugh Jackman.
It's the Gary Hart's Story. Uh,
it's directed by Jason Reitman.
I'm already promoting it.
They're not even done shooting
and I'm already promoting it.
That's how great of employee am a,
it's going to come out next year.
I've already seen like the dailies. It
looks, it looks freaking amazing. Um,
so I'm not gonna be able to
get to go to the game, but, uh,
Aaron Rodgers has hurt anyways,
but I've only been to Lambeau field
and went there a long time ago.
It was actually, you have explained the
skyline cafe in Appleton, Wisconsin and
Green Bay had a preseason game against
the Cleveland browns and Brett Farve was
still there.
That's how long ago this was.
Brett Farve was still there and
nobody was talking about him retiring.
It was Brett Farve. And, uh,
he played like the first quarter,
maybe into the second quarter.
So I got to see him play a little bit
there. I know it was just pretty seasoned,
so I kind of wanted to go back
there for a legit game, but, uh,
it didn't work out on this trip,
but, uh, it's already been awesome,
so thank you to everybody came up,
enjoy the music. Uh, and with them.
List the producer of the Monday
morning podcast and Thursday afternoon,
just portrait Friday.
Many more deposits.
Sometimes I don't want to
say the whole thing. Um,
he's gonna play some music here and
then we'll listen. Do you listen to a,
an old podcasts from a Thursday,
from a year gone by or possibly earlier
this year and I'm done talking and go
fuck yourselves. Have a great weekend.
You cuts and I'll talk to you on Monday.
His wife, what's her name
there? Heather Mills.
I'll read this real fast as short a wife
to serve Pol Pot or may listen to this
or me. Heather Mills said she gave Sir
Paul Mccartney a strict ultimatum as the
relationship blossomed. Quit
smoking marijuana. Marijuana.
Excuse me or forget walking
down the aisle. Huh?
I told him I would not get married to
him if he was taking drugs. I hate it.
Heather.
37 told London's Observer newspaper.
I could not have him lying to our child
about not taking drugs and then going
out for a sneaky puff.
He says he had a good incentive,
a good incentive to stop smoking
pot. Her ultimatum. Yeah.
You don't give a bill and I'll fix.
Excuse me yet.
Do you think John Lennon
would have taken that? No.
Balcony? Yeah, with the
one leg. One leg. Yeah.
It's Paul Mccartney.
He obviously didn't sign a prenup
because there's not a way to take that.
She wouldn't even brought it up.
This was before they got married.
She wanted him to stop smoking pot.
There is no way Paul Mccartney should
be taking an ultimatum from anybody.
That's what, one foot, the second wife,
not even at the one he wanted
the one he wanted and Mary died.
She's like the standard for
like for fucking decades.
Yeah. Yeah. Somebody
needs to help that guy.
He sat there and let
Linda Sing on those songs.
Where she is just making an abortion
of of a classic Beatles songs.
Just an open book and I
said live and let live.
Oh, he's playing. Hey Jude is,
oh my God.
Ah Dude.
She has such a bad singing voice that
the engineer's finally decided to just
isolate her mic and hit record because
you know real audio from a Paul Mccartney
concert where she was
singing background vocals.
I guess they turned her down in the mix,
but this guy said this is way too good.
I got share this with others. So he a
taped just her microphone. I'm guys,
hey Jude is be in a song.
I'm guessing she was probably kind of
concede to the guy and started actually
thinking that she was actually a music
and probably was just like out of the
band. Hi Bitch. Yeah, yeah. Oh, I'm
sure she probably, you know, they,
they knew she stunk and I get
more base and my monitor athletes
Shao
can hear what the fuck fucking playing.
She's the one every time
looking at the south point,
pointing at her ear and putting
our thumb up like more monitor.
I can't hear me louder in the mix.
You are loud.
Air phones that
tone and holds it.
This is the real deal.
Listen to it.
This is actually Linda Mccartney.
You'll think this is a joke. This is so,
this is the real deal.
Listen to this.
Yeah.
Hi Selena.
I'm hitting a leg every time
really bad right here.
What classic classic song.
This song is almost sacred.
They broke up.
We should have put it in a shower.
So,
so
what that visitor shower.
We got a square back then
when the saints come marching it.
Hey,
we got bonded. Look and
listen to little rock.
Listen to a role isn't to the golden smog.
Wow. Opinion Mirror. Well, grandma
bird
is
wailing his legs, so not a nothing
like bread. We also have a yoga.
His legs would be doing like the plaid
button down. I'll go, go, go, go.
She's dog.
He'll
Yoko Ono. No, go on.
It wasn't much better.
Do you ever see rock and roll circus?
The documentary is known
as she can't sing. No. I've
never heard any of this shit,
but she's more turned us on to this man.
You had like an all star band on
stage at John Lennon help me out.
And who was on? I'll make Ringo. Ringo
was the king of the all star band. No,
but this was nine drummers. Someone's
got to help us out here. No,
this was the finale finale.
So it was a John Lennon
I stage with Mick Jagger.
Eric Clapton aren't guitar. Jimmy Hendrix
guitars. Yes. Back had to be there. No,
that's it right there.
What about the Ho no,
that was part of the whole part of the
show. But if this one alley was alive,
this is, this is where they pretty much
like just a, did a lot, wants to rugs,
got together and just jams. But the
final song is what I'm getting at. Yeah.
It was lending on stage with Mick Jagger,
Eric Clapton,
our guitar and Hendrick's
guitars and they just,
how can you fuck that?
Fuck that legends.
So listen to Yoko Ono rectus
thing. It was the, uh,
the final song of this rock and roll
circus. That documentary, who has a,
Derrick has it. Did you fast forward
a little bit or, okay, listen to this.
So they're just jamming away,
right?
Like hope you guys,
that is a both. The guys
was like,
there's an app on her foot,
like he'll make,
can't make that sound.
Jimi Hendrix still playing like he
wouldn't stop and go, uh, looking at, uh,
did you think of Lennon but your
hundred spaces or something.
But one of them know like slapping should
have just turned around and gone to
John. You'll fucking lies.
How old's the floppy mark?
I'm going to whine about it. Hit her
over the head with a guitar. It's awful.
I know I'm not, I'm not available
harder this whole thing, but do,
do know she is school awful man.
Don't drug
program. What is this dog shit, man?
I don't know what it's a little known
fact that took Eric Clapton nine years to
tell his friend John Lennon that
he was in a disastrous marriage.
Yeah, exactly. Like it sounds like.
I don't know how to bring the head.
I just don't know how to bring it up.
We're doing a little call back though,
walking. Anybody who's helped me
before I got divorced that she stunk
your fucking life.
Miserable human being.
When I used to get together
songs at the local pub,
she sounds like it. This sounds like a
napalm strike on the Holcim in Israel.
That's what it sounds like.
Just screaming Vietnamese children.
I taught David, Texas.
Hey
Brad.
Well, Linda Mccartney, what a
page. I'm on tour with an a.
She was walking around
the parking lot one day.
She saw this truck driver had a
McDonald's bag on the floor of his trucks.
Fired his ass on the spot
for eating McDonald's.
Well,
can we can do it, dude. I mean there
was no, no meat whatsoever again.
She walked out there and fucking
started. His door was open. You know,
we're all standing there. She like, who's
truck is this that you're fucking gone.
Oh no shit.
Unbelievable a page.
I told you I love you guys are listened
to all every morning out here on tour.
I'm punching out. All right, let's
go to Randy in New York. Red Day. Yo,
what's up guys? Hey, y'all
going a little back before.
Do you think Paul Mccartney who is
using a, her leg is a bond at all.
Oh, smoking the other
pos. That's how the star,
that's where the ultimatum was to
stop smoking out of, out of my leg.
Mills is telling a beetle pot where me,
how bout uh,
me smoking pot or you give up your ass
outta here and try to find another beetle
who's been lottery. Saint does
one left regarding go you idiot.
So it wasn't for drugs.
We wouldn't have had the second half
of the Beatles' sergeant pepper's,
all of that. Right. It was drugs.
It was drugs that did that thank God in
earlier a girlfriend and give the same
ultimate and we wouldn't have all
that that came out. You wear a hat.
I want to hold your hand. The
Beatles. What you think it would,
they would have been like, like wouldn't
have gone down in history as, yeah,
they would have sounded like the Hanson
brothers had started smoking time to be
wasted and put here that those satin
major Rhett fucking outfits on.
So they sang a song called
the yellow submarine.
Pre drugs though, isn't it? No, no, no.
There is a definite line when they
discovered drugs and it is so apparent and
now someone is telling Paul
Mccartney to lay off the pot. Yeah,
I'd still have a a,
some of this and I'm still one little
puff and all of a sudden a brain cell gets
hit and it's a brilliant song
coming out. Remember me? Yeah.
Smoke your pot.
If you're hot.
She's pitching at him. Find
another beetle. Go ahead.
Go ahead. That's amazing.
I wonder why he, he is he too pussy to go?
Um, let's, let's, let's, let's be honest.
He has see this house you're living in
and that was because I was smoking pot
with my pals, smoking pot and doing a lot
more. I would just leave me, I came down,
I would just be, I'll be in the
house and go off and answer.
Let me show you something. Echo.
Echo. Okay. You see that shit.
That's the living room.
I will do whatever the fuck I want to do.
I just pointed a leg just,
I'd be like, listen, Ahab,
Ahab, fucking captain Ahab and
given you a lot of money. Look,
I'm just constantly pointed her foot.
Nobody,
no one's hot enough to be missing a
limb when I'm, I'm, I can get, I can he,
I bet you Paul Mccartney could
get a 21 year old dude that you
buy South beach. This isn't even
an issue that you have to say.
I bet you he can.
This Paul Mccartney,
the Beatles, this, these,
there's only two left.
They just sit there right when she's,
when she's talking shit to you, you just,
you just shake your head back and
forth like, hmm. And you just look,
keep looking at her until she said so.
And she and you just keep doing this.
You'd shake her head and look at it.
I didn't look at a foot once
again for Theresa. Just something.
She can't sit up.
He's looking to go and
which one is it again in a second.
Then knowing it and then knocking
on the fake one. I'm, hello.
I'm a Beatle. Bitch. Who fills
your closet with left shoes?
Paul? My fucking car. Fucking tiny. Maybe
that's your last name. Bitch.
How about the, and you know what,
I'm going to give you a new one of those
new wooden leg in a shape of a joint
with a foot in it just
painted ashy like it was fucking
one end. Somebody sucking on it. Paul.
I'm a fucking Cantonese
joint on the side of it.
Let's get a Frankie.
Okay.
Paul made a mistake. Uh, uh,
an album called rubber soul had my nails
be about an album called the rubber sole
and I'll hold your hand.
I never thought that in my life
that she loves you. Yay. Yay.
Yay Paul from a in it, but wasn't
that part of their greatness shit.
Hind hindsight looking at where they went.
They came up with that as like they
came out, they were like in sync,
but they rise.
They were the boy band of Liverpool.
Bigger than one hit wonders when
that fucking came out though.
They were super famous.
They would done.
Yeah. That stuff was, if they didn't,
if they didn't listen to Peter Noone
listened to Peter Noone stuff who didn't
progress on Tuesday. Um, Henry
the eighth and the eighth.
He was. He just dumb. He might've been
addressed as, he's like second verse,
same time and Ray, the
ACI am, it's just like
[inaudible] midnight runners should
have spoken for men to something.
Go.
That guy
walking around. One guy's a
thousand of those guys bands, guys,
but they never went on to smoke pot
and taking LSD and sit down with the
Maharishi and fucking get hammered
even phone. That shit, man.
Of course. Let's go to Paul
Jersey. He's got so much Paul.
Hey,
term pregnancy.
Whoa, whoa. Oh Wow.
Wow. Oh my goodness. Look at Eric Smith.
Erin Smith in the 70s completely wasted
that said best fucking music. Best Shit.
Then they get cleaned up and you get love
in an elevator. You got, you got there.
Most commercial success though,
after they got off the drugs,
let's go to which is weird.
Know Man.
Stick with the pro drug fucking slant
or the show that is for the instant
feedback bit ruining your dead. What did
I do say ruined your Beth. That's right.
Oh, we don't forget. We
don't forget Tonio and
broke my heart. Sicily. He
is the way that you open.
Hey Dro, let's go. You
killed my father drove.
Go. Amen. Two weeks ago,
but potter me, but you're
not a beetle. Yeah.
So you're not smoking.
Not Anymore.
Sure.
There you go. And blow and
blow. We'd rings and a face.
It sounds like he's on part right now.
We're talking a Beatle.
He should be able to take her leg off
and beat her over the head with it.
And she should still come back with a
loving smile or turn it into an instrument
like the, yeah, the, the thing
that you do, fucking trombone.
If you had to come home and
watch this bitch, I'm a, I'm a car holes
in it. I'm gonna turn this to a big flute.
You're leg is a giant
playing and her leg.
I want you to play your leg.
If something smoking to enhance
my high and seeing the back.
I want you sing the chorus, the yellow
submarine base. That's why I smoke weed.
All your legs. We, oh, it's so good.
Hello.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it's the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
November 2nd,
2009 can you believe that?
It's November. Oh my God.
Where's this year? God, Jesus.
Every year it goes by faster.
I know. I always do that joke,
but that's what everybody says.
Can you believe it's November? Yes,
I can. You know what
gave it away? October.
That was the big hint that
fucking November was coming up.
You know Halloween. I remember
that. I know that's on the 31st
so yes, I can believe and yes,
yes, it does go by quicker.
Obviously it goes by quick.
I think about it when you were a child,
you know if you were four years old,
if a year went by,
that was 25% of your life. Yes.
So it definitely dragged on.
Plus you had two giants telling you what
the fuck to do all day and what to eat
right? Well, when you're 41
years old, a year goes by.
That's like a, it's kind of math. I
can't do, I don't know what that is.
What does that one, one 80th of
my life. You know, it's funny,
it's actually Sunday night right now and
I just settled down to do the podcast.
I had the apartment to
myself and I'm thinking,
all right can bang out a nice hour and
all of a sudden the windows open and I
hear somebody driving by
listening to this song.
This is how we do it. It's Friday night,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I'm like, who the fuck would
still be listening to that music?
And Lo and behold, it's the woman
I share my life with polling in,
listen to a song that
sucked when it came up.
Bullshit you to that station all the time.
All I want to do with chromosomes.
Yeah.
See he listened. He listened to all of
that shit. Listen, I'm going to punt.
I'm going to get satellite radio so I
can listen to really bad hair metal and
you can know what the
fuck I was listening to.
You know what you smell like right now?
You smell like that overpowering air
freshener that you put in the fucking car.
I smile. It's something different.
What do you smell like? Huh?
It's, it's, I dunno what it smell it get
away from me. I've got to do a podcast.
I can't be smelling smells. What
is it? What's the name of it? What?
Exotic fragrance and get
away from me. I said, okay,
well then I'm going to stick with that.
Then gather your belongings and
get out of the room. So you guys,
this is how you handle a little more
and they deliberately act moody.
You just said get away from me and
I'm really, really wet. No, I didn't.
I sit in a comical way.
If I see if I'm holding a microphone
with an orange fucking wind screen,
you can't take it seriously.
You can not take it seriously.
It was being an asshole. Yeah, I do. I
get away with it. What I would want to,
because I'm running shit. Get out
woman. Go make me. You see here,
which will make me see
which, oh, beat it. Come on.
I want to talk about Halloween and how
I thought we had the fucking the best
shit on the block.
But yeah,
he's fucking assholes up the street.
All right, let me back up near.
You need to walk so I can tell this story.
All right.
You and your fragrance need to get out
of the room here for a second. Okay.
She just smelled her rest. And
guys, I like it. I had Jaya as in,
oh, that's how you keep it fresh
people. It's the fights and then the,
the making up and whatnot.
Um, why did I just do that to,
cause I was annoyed.
I thought he had the apartment to myself,
so I just decided to be a Douche. So
there you go. I'm Douche bag of the week.
Um, I pulled it out the
last seconds. Um, anyways,
so for Halloween,
and those of you who are longtime
listeners of the podcast know that I, I'm,
I'm kind of into Halloween.
I like it.
I decided to embrace the
holidays a couple of years ago,
rather than just being like,
dude, this is fucking bullshit.
It's just to know the core be fucking
strategy. Gimmes Buma fuck Molly. Um,
I find just said, you know what?
Fuck it. So, um, you know, last year,
if you guys are on my myspace page,
so I'm sticking it out there.
I have pictures of the Pumpkin I carve
last year at carved an ACDC pumpkin.
That was this shit.
Okay.
It was the shit and this year as
like, how do I top this? And, um,
I was trying to think of the scariest
thing I could think of to carve into a
pumpkin. And I ended up carving
the, uh, the Federal Reserve Bank.
I know I'm going crazy.
I can still smell that fucking fragrance.
It's overpowering, whatever
it is. Oh God. It's awful.
Jesus smells like flowers and
soap all at the same time.
You know, one of those things
individually, they're good, you know,
like brushing your teeth and orange
juice, but if you put them together, um,
so anyways, yeah, carved the
Federal Reserve Bank. It's
the fucking shit. All right.
Uh, go on to my myspace page. I've
got a whole picture of it, you know,
and then I fucking made pumpkin bread
afterwards and I fucking toasted the
seeds. I was like a
native American, you know,
after I killed the Pumpkin,
I used all the parts.
I took out the Pumpkin's Achilles tendons.
I made a fucking jump rope out of it,
you know,
and I looked out the window,
I saw some trash and I
got a little teary eyed.
And that's what I did that I just used
the crying Indian hacky reference.
That was funny. Way Back on
VH one. Standup spotlight.
Do you guys ever used to watch that?
And the old people out there,
the standup spotlights when they were
just scraping the bottom of the barrel of
anybody remotely left.
Funny from the 1980s half the people
on there were like substitute teachers.
They had chalk on the back of their
pants come in a little so deal. Ooh,
fucking a racers and they'd
some hour making money.
You know, what am I
talking about? So anyway,
so not only do I have the Federal Reserve
pumpkin cause I figured, you know what?
Anybody can try and scare
the kids. You know who, who,
whoever tries to scare the parents.
That's what I,
that's why I decided to carve the Federal
Reserve Bank and did it fucking three
d style.
It's the Shit I had flames behind
it actually tried to carve.
We own you in reverse writing.
So it would come up against the wall.
But I failed just because I don't have,
I don't have the tools. All right?
All these assholes who are making
these fucking insane pumpkin's.
Half of these comments,
they just go,
you go on a website and
you just buy something.
You just trace it and
it tells you what to do.
You don't have fucking third
grader could do it, you know?
And then you get all these,
all these little double edged
knives and all his shit. I had a,
I had a fucking paring knife,
the same knife.
I used to cut up an apple.
I carved in the Federal Reserve Bank.
Okay. And I was going to have, we own you,
but that part fail. But whatever.
So I had that. And then I also had,
I had full size candy bars.
You had your choice.
If you came to my house on Halloween,
you had your fucking choice
of a Hershey bar without nuts.
Cause God knows all these fucking pussy
kids are allergic to everything he can't
have all month.
He has almonds.
It countered back balances his Prozac
and then it's just crazy until Wednesday
really, lady, did you ever think you
should have died and not had a kid?
Wow. Wow. That was mean. It's not
what I was trying to say, but I was,
I was trying to, Sam's talking about
natural selection there that uh,
whatever's in you was so fucking weak
that your kid can't even have nuts.
You know what I mean? I mean, every,
everybody's allergic to getting fucking
stabbed. But when you're like allergic,
I can't have food. You shouldn't
be alive. All these fucking people,
all these lactose intolerant fucking
people clogging up the highways.
All of you.
You should not be alive.
You're only alive
because, uh, Jesus Christ,
I already talked myself into a
corner. Why Bill? Why are they alive?
Because of modern medicine. They're just
using you as a fucking revenue stream.
All right. Who's kidding? Who? I
would've been dead a hundred years ago.
I would've been,
I had a ruptured appendix in sixth grade.
That would have been if I would've been
on like a little house in the prairie,
just laying there sweating under fucking
58 blankets in an outhouse is not what
they did with their sick.
You should just stick them under blankets.
Start dabbing at their forehead.
Does this make it better? No,
it doesn't. No, it does.
It's something inside of me exploded
and now the poison is a having a party
and he should take me out back and
shoot me like old yeller. So anyways,
I got this fucking insane fucking pumpkin.
All right.
Okay. Anybody can, can, can, can
carve in some shit that doesn't exist.
That'll scare the fuck out of you.
This actually exists and is actually was
actually fucking everyone who's walking
up the stairs, all of them. All of
them should have been like, Holy Shit.
That's it right there. That is the
devil. That is the fucking devil.
I love that Pumpkin.
It looks great.
It's saying something and it's
scaring the shit out of me.
It's working on all three levels.
It is a fucking triple threat. Like,
like the way people used to be in show
business back in the day where they could
sing and they could dance
and they could tell jokes.
That's what that Pumpkin Pumpkin is,
you know, that's the, I, you know,
whether all that was, is what I was
hoping they would think. But they didn't,
I didn't get one comment. Why did
he carve a building into a pumpkin?
I don't understand. Is that a Walmart?
Oh, make good. Walmart's fucking scary.
You know,
if somebody came with the stairs,
who fucking actually tried to
start a hardware store anyways,
so I had fired this fucking
insane pumpkin. All right. Um,
had my fucking door all lit up and all
that type of shit and I got full size
fucking candy bars. Okay. For all these
cute little kids coming up. All right.
But uh, something, and this is going
to be at, word's going to get out.
This dude's got a fucking, you know, he,
he carved a library into a pumpkin
and he's got, who gives a fuck?
The guy's a Weirdo,
but he's got full sized fucker candy bars
and the candy bars that we recognize.
Kit Kat, who? Reese's peanut
butter cups or fucking or Hershey,
what is it? Not Hershey but Hershey milk
chocolate. Okay. Those were all fucking,
we know what those are. So even
though he's a Weirdo, it's wrapped.
We understand that there's no poison it.
So I'm thinking I'm going to be the shit.
These kids are going to be clamoring
around me like I'm fucking Dick Clark in
1965. Right. But no,
I got fucked because the people up the
street, they were, they went all out.
This dude up the street, his
son and daughter, his son,
fuck head that he is now his son
and his daughter put on a show like,
uh,
like Michael Jackson.
They were doing a tribute to Michael
Jackson and it was fucking insane.
They had a stage,
they had like monitors.
It looked like a fucking rock show was
going to happen and they had a show like
every 20 minutes or every half hour
and a whole crowd would gather.
I didn't even get to see it. I was down
the street with my full size candy bar.
Am I fucking new world order pumpkin
going? Where is everybody? You know,
I've got a fucking seven 11 here,
sort of. This is my fucking kitchen.
Looked like literally like I robbed
the seven 11 and rather than taking the
money I took all the candy out of it.
That's what the fuck it looked like.
I and I can't get a God damn fuck.
I can't get anybody to come because
everybody's running up the street cause
these kids were killing it.
You know,
Neil went up there with
their mom and they came back.
Oh my God.
It was awesome.
They even had the car from the fucking
whatever video and he literally got in it,
Blah Blah Blah.
Right.
Just wanted to fucking slap both of
them. Um, no I didn't. I want to,
I was fucking pissed.
I was literally reduced to yelling
off of my balcony going as people were
walking, did go up to go see the
Michael Jackson thing. I was going, Hey,
we got candy up here. We
got candy up here. Right?
Think about the 41 year old white male
yelling down to children that he's got
candy. It was really, it
was really bad. But, uh,
eventually I get got rid of all of it.
And uh,
I discovered a new pet peeve that I have.
Um, I don't like trick or treaters who
look like they're fucking 26. All right.
You know who you are. You're too fucking
old. It's not cute anymore. You know,
you're a Douche. And um, the last group
of people came up as was fucking unreal.
His kid had a better mustache
then I could grow. You know,
he didn't have a mustache. We know what
I'm saying. If you're too fucking old.
And he was actually saying she fucking
hates them too when she wanted to do was
have a bag of apples. And when people
came up and they would do it too old,
she wanted to give them apples instead
of candy. I'm like, yeah, that's great.
And then they get down to the front
yard and they'd throw it through your
fucking window.
Why don't we just hand out baseballs?
But I understood what she
was talking about. You know,
the fuck is wrong with
you. How old are you? Okay.
You should be going to a Halloween party
trying to fuck somebody dressed like a
tube of toothpaste or whatever it is.
That's what you supposed to be doing.
You're not supposed to be coming to
my door. Fucking Yo. It was annoying.
I should have had a little bite size ones.
Anyways,
so I actually was walking my dog this
morning and I was seeing all like the
candy wrappers on the ground and all
the fat kids that couldn't wait til they
got home.
And um,
and um, I dunno, they will all bite size.
None of them were full size.
I had the best candy on the fucking block
and I got trumped by this Vegas show
up the fucking street.
Really? I don't know,
just annoying noise the shit out of me.
And I also to walk my dog, I actually, I,
I pick up litter because a,
I think I live in a nice neighborhood and
I don't like when fucking people throw
shit on the ground.
So I'm sitting there picking up these
little candy wrappers with my God damn dog
and uh, came across a milky
way that that bugged me.
You know,
we do,
you know why even give out candy
if he'd given out a milky way,
that's such a fucking cop
out. It's like, uh, I can't,
I can't even fucking give a fuck
about hauling. You don't Milky Way.
The Milky Way is like,
it's like
if John Oates was a candy bar, he
be, he'd be a fucking Milky Way.
That's what I'm trying to say.
All right.
If you don't listen to fucking hall and
I'll cheat and you don't get the joker,
right. He, it's, it's something,
it nugget new is John Oates.
Okay.
New get need some sort of, it needs
something with it. You know what I mean?
It's like a Andrew Ridgeley who some of
the other famous duos that broke off and
one guy just totally fucking made it
and the other guy was the human fucking
version of, of new get with nothing
in it. Can you think of anybody else?
I know fucking insync Justin
Timberlake was the almonds.
Those other four mother fuckers.
That's what they were.
When Justin was in there, it was
a snickers bar. You took them out.
It was a Milky Way and nobody fucking
gave a shit. And that was the end of them.
That was the fucking end of him.
Who gives out Milky Way. You know,
fucking, you're not even
trying. Not even fuck.
I had full sized fucking
candy bar and I was,
I was hanging out screaming at people
trying to get them to come up to my
fucking place. It was pathetic.
But I'll tell you right now,
the pumpkin bread was to shit.
All right, let's move on here. Um,
let's talk about my life.
What I have going on. Um,
I'm trying to hype shit that I have
going on, um, earlier in the podcast.
So here goes this week. I'm going
to be a town hall in New York City.
I'm not the town hall, the
town hall theater. And uh,
I don't even know if
there's any tickets left,
but I just like saying I'm going to
be doing a theater in New York City.
Do you realize that? You realize
how huge that is for me. You know,
way back in the day when I was
a youngster with a big Red Afro,
wondering if I'd ever get on stage in
New York City just to do five fucking
minutes at one o'clock in the morning,
you know,
and here it is,
38 years later,
I'm finally getting to do a theater.
Now I'm actually really excited and um,
I'm doing my special next month and um,
you know, this is going to be, you know,
weren't basically if you go to that
show or you're going to see basically my
special essentially.
So I got that going on and a,
that's November 6th, November
7th, I'm going to be doing comics,
come home with Denis leary,
the 15th anniversary.
It's for the Cam Neely, um, the Cam
Nealy House that helps families,
um,
of people stricken with cancer gives them
a place to stay rather than sitting in
some awful hospital.
They actually get a nice home to stay in.
So that's a wonderful cause that will
be at a guidance arena with the BU
terriers play. And, uh, I believe there's
only a few tickets left for that one.
So that's what I got going on. And later
on the month I'll be in Tempe, Arizona.
Really looking forward to that Gig and uh,
and the rest you can go to [inaudible]
dot com borr for uh, for date. See,
and that's why I don't hype shit in
the middle because it's not funny.
It's not fucking interesting. And uh,
then what happens? You're like, what?
This guy's going to riff about fucking
candy bars and musicians I don't give a
fuck about and then tell me
where he's going to be at.
Let me tell you guys a story. The
other day I decided, you know,
I really need to get my ass in shape
so I don't look like a fat fuck on TV
during my special.
So I'm,
I have problems with joining gyms
because I'm always on the road.
I have to freeze my membership and
all that type of shit and he's,
I just throw the money away.
So I had been working out outside
basically in my apartment.
And then I do cardio outside just like
that fucking guy with all the Matthew
mcconaughey. There you go. You know,
I do keep my shirt on and I don't run
down the street with fucking palm tree
leaves. Like I'm trying to fly and it's
1898. I don't do that shit. All right.
But I've definitely been going on hikes.
So I found this hill out here and uh,
being a big football fan,
I remember how Jerry Rice used to
run up this fucking hill, you know,
to get in training for
the, uh, the NFL season.
And I found a hill and I've been
running up this fucking thing and uh,
I've been loving every
minute of it. And, um,
I went up to go do it and I came home
and my fucking, I couldn't find my keys
like an asshole. I left the, uh,
my pocket open on my sweatpants and
because I'm old and when I run down the
hill, I can't run down the
hill. I have to sort of, Gallup,
that's fucking pathetic.
And a,
I was going really fast and I guess it
kind of flew out a fucking rattlesnake
took it.
I don't know what happened,
but I went back up to it or try and
find them and I don't have them.
And you're like, wow, what's the big
fucking deal? You know? Why don't you,
Oh shit. Did I just fucking
knock something out here?
What the hell just happened?
Hello. Test one, two. I know you can
hear this, but I can't hear myself.
What the fuck is going on? Hold on. Hello.
I know it's recording. What the fuck
is the problem line in? That's good.
Your phones. That's fine. Hello? Test.
There we go. I got it back. Sorry.
Jesus Christ. You know what is my
fucking rooms getting so God damn hot,
I have to turn on the fucking ceiling fan.
Hang on a second.
I can't do this all once.
You know, if at any sort of class, I'd
edit that part out, but I'm not going to.
So anyways, yeah. So I lost my
fucking keys. And like anyone,
any normal person, if I had a normal
fucking car, oh, that's what I did.
I turned this thing down. That's
what happened. Ah, there we go.
Hello. Test one, two. Wow.
Just when you thought it couldn't get
any worse. This is why it's free folks.
This is why it is fucking free.
Like a one man band here.
I shouldn't have like
symbols between my legs.
How fucking easy was it to be a goddamn
entertainer back in the day that, that,
that that's what you could have you ever
seen one of those one man band guys.
It's never good.
It's never fucking good when somebody
does like a throwback to that shit and
they get symbols between their legs and
a base drum behind their back. Great.
And it turned the fan on too high and
I'm blowing shit off my fucking desk. Um,
anyways. Yeah. So I can't find
my keys. And um, you know,
the house keys,
no big deal.
But the problem was was it was also the
key to my car and I drive a hybrid and
it's this special fucking key.
It's a special key people.
They couldn't just give me a regular
key where you stick it in the door and
shove it in the ignition.
This is like one of these keys where
you can have it in your pocket and you
don't need to take it out and then you
just fucking reach and touch the door and
it magically unlocks because some sort
of wave is coming out of the pocket,
going to the door lock,
bouncing back off and putting cancer
into your testicles. You know?
That's what I'm basically doing
what I'm risking ball cancer,
so I don't have to fucking unlock
my door the conventional way.
But the bottom line is you want to be,
you're probably wondering, well bill,
how much does this pocket ball
cancer fucking Karachi cost?
Evidently it's between two and 300 bucks.
I remember when I bought the car,
make sure you don't lose this merch.
Shoot all losers cruise, of course,
the to $224 to poker and blah, blah,
blah. I was thinking in my head, wow,
that sounds like a fucking rip off to
me. Really, that little plastic thing.
So,
I don't know.
I went back up the hill and I tried to
find the fucking thing and I couldn't,
once again, you know, I went up
there and it's actually really these,
these unbelievable houses like um,
like rich people, but like
classy rich, not like, uh,
not Jerry Jones rich, you know what I
mean? Classy, tasteful, rich, you know,
and I was walking down the hill and I
was looking for the keys and I came down
and this is fucking old guy is walking
up the street and right as I was about
ready to say hello to him, you
know, rich people are so, like they,
some of them just have,
they,
they have an inability to
like just have a conversation.
It's like I'm walking down the street,
he's coming up the hill,
he sees me and I'm just be like, hey,
how are you? That's all I'm going to say.
He just, this is what, this is
how he greets me. He just goes,
beautiful fall after noon.
I didn't know what the
fuck to say to that.
And he said it that loud and it took
him that like he drew out the words
beautiful fall after noon.
You don't, what should have happened right
after he said that, you know, and those,
the original monster movies of Hollywood,
you know,
that church organ that they, you
know, and then the lightening strikes,
that's what the fuck should happen.
After that guy talked, it's like, Whoa,
what are you just naming
shit that you like?
Like I didn't know socially what I was
supposed to say after beautiful fall
after noon,
um,
half off Budweiser's at a teddy bar.
What do you say to that? I don't know
how the fuck to say to the guy and I,
I just sort of went, yeah, yeah, it is.
It's a nice one.
Just kept fucking walk.
Ah,
with the fire, it was like, I was trying
to think like, what question I could have.
I don't think it was playing
a board game in his head
or he played the first five notes,
so to a song and I said, ah,
what is the name of that
song? Uh, tell me what is it?
It's called beautiful fall afternoon.
That's what it's called. Um, anyway,
so I walked back up there and I just kept
saying to people, edge a JD as you've,
as you having to she a shed a
quiche. And they'd be like, no, no,
I didn't. Um, but if I find them I will,
ah, and I had no information to
give them and I was just like, yeah,
just sort of stick them
on a rock stick on a rock.
And maybe I'll come walking by and I'll
fucking, you know, but I held out hope.
I was like, you know what, it's
a park. There's a lost and found.
I'll go there tomorrow in
the lost and found is open.
And I went there hoping against hope
that for once in my life I lost something
in public and somebody
actually returned it, you know?
Do you remember that from back in
the day when I lost my cell phone,
my girlfriend since I been with her
has probably lost three cell phones and
anytime she loses his cell phone,
all she does is call it.
She calls it. And not only does
somebody pick it up, it is the greatest
person on the planet. You know, I should
just call up and I'm thinking my head.
Then I was going to answer this shit.
It's gone. Just like mine is always gone.
And then she calls, you know,
one and a half ring. Somebody
just picks it up. Hello.
Well, yes I do. Absolutely. Come
on over. I'll give it to you.
I actually just bake some cookies.
Come on over.
I'll give you a fresh cookies and your
fucking cell phone back because that's
how your life works,
right?
I lose my mind in the back of a fucking
car is fucking douchebag is driving me
to the airport.
I realize it like a half hour later.
I know we still working and the phone is
on and it's ringing in his fucking back
seat and the cont doesn't answer it.
So that has been my experience.
So I go over to the little ranger
Rick thing going, oh please.
Then maybe this is the one time,
keep a positive attitude,
put it out to the universe.
I'm going to get my $200 set of keys
back and of course I show up and they're
like, uh, no. Nobody has
returned any keys. You,
if you want to check back later
and get giggly, it really, really,
am I really going to come back later? You
know, I'm not going to come back later,
so just spare me this speech or right.
Just go fucking change the
chances of fire sign out there.
Why don't you just go fucking do that?
You're like, oh man. At the Park Ranger,
because I've ran with my AMF
fucking sweatpants with the sides.
Unzipped like an asshole, like
a fucking asshole. All right.
Last week I talked about
this guy who I wanted to uh,
flatten his nose while I,
I sent my fist all the way to the back
of his fucking cranium stopping just
short of the hypothalamus and I was
talking about fights and I'm just how when
you get older you have to walk away from
fights because there's no winning them.
There really isn't. When you get
old, it's just like, okay, either a,
I get out of the car and I get the
living shit kicked out of me. Right.
Or B I win and then I get sued.
Right.
And the older you get the,
the the greater chance of the first one,
which is w I dunno. What do you think's
worse getting the shit kicked out of you?
I think getting sued is worse,
but as long as it depends
on the level of ass kicking.
I don't want to lose a tooth, but you
know, if you want to beat me down,
I have a headache for three days.
I'd rather have that than deal with you
fucking taking my money. So anyways.
Um,
so a lot of people sent me
in some unbelievable stories
about fights that either
they walked away from
or that they got into.
One of them is actually a case pending,
so I'm not allowed to talk about it.
So I'll basically,
I'll skim over it is basically a kid is
walking down the street and three drunk
guys start giving him shit. He gives him
shit back. They give him some more shit.
And he says, Oh yeah, the guys
are real tough with three.
None of you would fight me one on
one and this one kid goes, all right,
I'll fight you. So they square
off, they'd throw a few.
And the though the kid who
was just part, you know, the,
the innocent kid connected hit the kid.
The kid falls down and hits the back of
his head on the pavement. He, you know,
and he's not fucking moving. And the
kid's like, holy fuck, what did I do?
So he's kind of walking away,
but he's also concerned,
his big fucking mistake was
he actually gave a shit.
And uh, then the cops showed up. He was
still in sight and he got fucking, uh, uh,
did they arrest him? I can't remember.
All I know was in the end of it, this,
there's three of them and only one of him.
And he ended up getting sued and lost
something about a preemptive strike.
Can you fucking believe that? I was like,
Oh, I'm sorry. Was I supposed to let, uh,
the one guy with the two other friends,
he hit me a couple times and then I
was supposed to punch back is fucking
unbelievable. It's
unbelievable. Just A, I dunno.
So there was a lot of people going like,
I want to kick the shit out of this guy.
What should I do? You know what he should
do? He should just fucking walk away.
Just walk away and just forget
about the whole fucking thing.
And don't even tell yourself that lie
that he'll get his, he'll get his,
cause you know what, they
don't, they don't get there.
So you know what they do is
they get punched in the face.
Maybe in the worst case scenario
is they win 10 grant. Um,
they don't, they don't. I, I've lived
long enough to realize that, you know,
when the bad guy gets his in the
movies, that's when it happens. Okay.
The rest of them go on to
live very successful lives.
They have great looking girlfriends.
They a porous raw sewage into drinking
water and they find some other Dick to
take the fall for it.
And then they buy land in South America
and they leave the country and they're
fine. They're fucking fides. So, uh,
you're better to just just walk away.
Somebody gave me some great
advice saying that, uh, the,
he used to get into fights all the time.
This is so simple.
I never even thought of it.
He just bought a heavy bag and he would
come home and he would just beat the
shit out of the bag and he felt way
better and there was no lawsuits.
And then certain days when
he wanted to murder somebody,
he would take a baseball bat and
just slam it into the heavy bag.
And he would feel phenomenal
afterwards. And, uh,
I, I liked, I want to, I want
to believe that that works.
I don't know. I have an insane
temper. I take it to the point of,
I want to feel that other guy quit.
That's how mad I am.
I want to beat the fuck out of you.
I want you to fight back,
but I want to feel the moment where you
fucking quit. You know how sick is that?
That's how mad,
I just can't see that getting that out
with the fucking heavy bag. All right,
so let's read a couple of stories here.
These were very long.
This was a very passionate subject.
Um,
so forgive me with my awful reading.
Here it goes.
I'm gonna read a couple of
these. Um, all right. Uh,
here's,
here's the classic like this.
This is like anger that will come
out of you 20 years from now.
Here's a great story here.
A bill, I sympathize about
the whole fight thing. Um,
it seems like anytime some asshole
decides to start shit with me,
it will happen in a war in a way that I
can't retaliate without either getting
arrested or sued. Literally what I was
just talking about. He goes, so anyways,
I was at a packed bar with some
friends the other night and uh,
we had gotten there about a half prior
and I had about a one beer in me,
so I wasn't even remotely drunk. Um, I
guess the place was packed. So anyways,
he's a I, she says, I'm,
I was making my way through the crowd
with a pint glass in my hand trying to
navigate to the bathroom along the way,
some scrawny little cunt who apparently
has had way too much to drink,
backs into me and spills half my beer
and make a habit out of quickly saying,
excuse me, and thank you
whenever I walk through a crowd,
because I figure people are more apt to
let you through if you're polite about
things. This prick turns around
and says, this is the guy who,
who bumps into him and spills
half his, his beer. He said,
this prick turns around and says,
what the fuck is your problem?
And knocks my drink out of my hand.
Jesus Christ. You gotta be able to take
a fucking wrench to that guy's head.
Um,
he said at this point,
one of his friends jumps on him trying
to break it up while the little bitch
keeps talking shit.
So I tell him to go fuck himself.
It was going to talk shit till the
prick would, uh, would throw a punch.
But just at that moment,
a guy standing next to us wearing a
blazer but with some kind of shirt sweater
that was,
that wasn't buttoned down,
tells me forcefully keep walking.
At that moment I figured it was one of
the bouncers pissed off over having lost
the drink and being insulted. Uh, I head
to the bathroom, my window to fight.
That shit had open and close so quickly
that I didn't get a chance at any
vindication.
When it got to the bathroom,
I noticed that the guy who I thought
was a bouncer wasn't, maybe he was,
maybe he was this little clowns,
a bodyguard, but I couldn't tell.
He didn't seem like one,
it didn't seem like one of his friends
because the little con in his friends
were all dressed the same way with
designer ripped jeans and open button down
shirts with necklaces and shit.
Basically they all look like they were
members of some eighties rock band that
was still touring but couldn't get but
could only get gigs in a dive bar. Um,
now my chant, my choices are either, okay,
now he's in the bathroom. Uh, he says,
now my choices are either walk
back to my group without a beer
or a the bitch move of telling one of
the bouncers and seeing if I can get that
prick tossed out. Um, I could
also go and confront them,
but even if I could take the bodyguard,
um,
what kind of person goes to a bar dressed
with that ed hardy clothing with a
Bodeger. What did I just miss here? Sorry.
This is really fucking long
and I'm seeing double here. Uh,
fuck you just killed the whole story bell.
What is wrong with you? Confront him.
Uh,
which from his size,
I think I stood a good chance as
long he was an MMA fighter. Uh,
this was in New Jersey.
Mind you. So I thought, uh,
I thought considering he was Italian
looking and had a girl that was way out of
his league, maybe he was connected
to some bullshit like that. Maybe a,
the little pricky even had a gun or a
knife on him because stupid shit like that
is happening thing.
I didn't want to take any shit from him,
but I'm not about to get shot
over a beer. Um, anyways, it's,
so that's what he ends up doing.
He goes,
I ended up walking back to my group
without a beer and hiding my bad mood for
the rest of the night.
One on one with either one of those cons,
I would have been fine.
I'm five,
1,195 pounds and mostly muscle and
I've never lost a fight. Then again,
I've only been in a few. I'll
spare the rest of this shit. Um,
I don't know if he's asking me
what I can't even remember. I just,
I get a headache when I have to read
that much. So you know what I mean?
It's like,
and do you think that little,
maybe that little fuck we'll get his
because he's so like I could see knocking
it over and be like, dude,
what the fuck's your problem?
That's sort of your average asshole and
a Barbara to then slap it out of your
hand. He's got that Napoleon thing where
he's got something to prove, I guess.
Um, I dunno, my question is,
what do you do with that anger?
What do you do with that fucking
anger? Anyways, his and Alon, Bill, uh,
you were talking about this week about
nearly getting into a fight with dead
Dick and the green sedan.
Well,
I admit that this wasn't
anywhere close to me fighting.
It was still a fucking horror
story while it happened. All right,
here's one here that will leave
you with a lot of anger. Uh,
I was about six months into my standup
career and a friend of mine asked me to
do a show with him at this bar that
paid him a, that pay would pay $20.
I was psyched because it
would be my first page show.
I did the show and got a
decent amount of laughs.
I thought I did fucking horribly,
but uh,
if they left then I'm not going to
complain. So he gets paid his money.
The next day I'm walking,
I'm walking home from school
and I'm cutting through
the basketball courts where
a drug dealer,
I know we'll call him drug dealer number
one is sitting there with one of his
friends, the friends he was sitting with
kind of look like ghost face killer,
but he had a stare of a potential rapist.
Next thing I know,
I'm passing this guy and he stops me.
He tells me that if I don't give
him my wallet, which is visible,
which was visibly in my front pocket,
he was going to just stop me and take it.
He takes it and empties my lunch money.
Luckily, or I thought, luckily I kept a
special 20 and a different compartment.
Now, this is a lot of things a lot of
comedians do, or people who when they,
they set off on a dream,
the first amount of money they get,
it's usually not a lot of money.
So they either frame the
check or they save the dollar,
the five bucks of the 20.
So I'm imagining that this is what
this young comic was trying to do.
So he kept a $20 in the, in a
different compartment. I said, well,
he rummaged through the entire wallet,
put back my large library card,
the illiterate cunt,
and eventually found the $20 bill.
He threw the wallet my chest and asked
me why I lied to him when he asked me if
I had any other money than any
other money than the lunch money.
I actually told the,
the guy mugging me the history of
this hidden $20 bill as he goes.
As I just typed that last sentence,
I just imagined my head slamming into
the keyboard. Um, he says, what a,
what a fag. I was, um, so anyways,
this motherfucker told me that
if I told him a good joke,
maybe I'd get the $20 back.
This is really your inexperience as a
comedian because there's no joke you're
going to be able to tell. So
anyways, here we go. He said, well,
I used to tell these off of one liners
when I first started because my self
confidence would dwindle left at 10
to 15 seconds. So I stammered out,
stammered out.
I knew this girl is so stupid.
The only reason why she knew her
ABC's was because of hepatitis.
So then the drug dealer,
he faked laughed like a fucking maniac,
straightened up into a serious face and
was just like, get the fuck Outta here.
Wow. Ah, Jesus.
That'll age you about fucking eight
years. Anyways, the rest of it,
needless to say,
I took it like a bitch,
but if this story didn't have a punchline
in and of itself, here's the kicker.
Literally less than a week later after
this incident, this drug dealer from,
from my school, big black kid
with a voice like Mickey Mouse,
it's a fucking spectacle.
Tells me that drug dealer number one stop
hanging out with the ghost face killer
guy because he's an
undercover fucking cop.
So this dude got mugged by
an undercover fucking cop.
So for all you, for all your talk
about getting screwed by corporations,
that's the worst case of being deep dick
by the man that's ever happened to me.
And then I realized in retrospect that
even though I lost the first remanence of
what I'd hope B would
be a successful career,
the losing of my first $20
was well worth the story.
I still hope that cop is
shot in the line of duty,
in skull fucked by a gang of junkies.
See that? That's the fucking anger.
That is the anger. Um, I dunno,
I dunno how many listeners I have at
this point cause I don't really hype this
fucking thing and I never bring
it up at shows. Are there any, uh,
psychologists out there?
You know, psychologists,
like they know what to do with anger.
It's fucking sweater wearing douche bags
just sitting there. They're loafers.
He ever go to therapy. He's to fucking
tell him shit. And then just like, Whoa,
what do you think?
You think that,
what would happen if you would do
something like that? It's just like,
it really is. That's
all you got. You know,
they just basically get you to pour out
all your shit and then you've got to
sort of figure it out. I don't even what
the f you know, it's fucking hilarious.
Had been in therapy for a while now
obviously it's not fucking working.
I'm anyways, this plow ahead here. Um,
did I talk about this last week?
Somebody sent me a, uh, somebody sent,
oh, somebody sent me a, an
email and was talking about my,
um, why are they like now? I hope it's,
this podcast has been loud enough.
I think it is.
Um,
somebody sent me an email talking about
some new movie coming out and in this
subject, the thing, the,
the line in the movie,
the lion on the subject line said another
save the black kid movie and it said
bill from various clips on Youtube.
I know you have some disdain for
racist movies. I was just wondering,
what's your feeling on the new one
coming out with Sandra Bullock called the
blind side?
Yeah,
I guess it's about her helping some,
a black kid. All right. First of all,
this is what I love about this email is,
um,
and this was something that I've learned
in standup comedy is you ha you can't
control how people process what you say.
Um,
I've never done a bit about another
about save a black kid movies.
The name of the bit was, uh,
white people are evil movies.
That's what it is. And I don't have,
obviously I have disdained
for racist movies,
but like what the fuck movie was I
talking about in my last special,
that one about the black swim team.
Uh, what the fuck was it called?
Poolside.
I can't ever remember.
What was it called against the tide?
The fuck was that movie called whatever.
Whatever that fucking movie was
called chlorine. What was it called?
I did that job for like
fucking a year on stage.
If you guys seen that new movie came
out, labile blots. I can't, yeah.
Trying to jog if my, I have
no memory. But anyways,
that movie is not an example of a
racist movie that's a movie about race.
Okay.
And, uh, you know, this is just a podcast
listener. So what the food, you know,
I'm not really going to give
this guy shit about that,
but I've actually had people write
reviews about my act and says,
and was describing some of the stuff I
talked to be talks about the difference
between men and women. Uh, he
does racist jokes. He does.
Bababa it's like,
I don't do I do racial jokes
about race are racial jokes.
Okay.
A movie about race is a,
is a, you could say it's a,
I guess a racial movie or, yeah.
You'd say that it's not racist.
A racist movie would be, um, I dunno,
that's a fucking good example of
it. What does it good? I mean,
Mississippi burning is not a racist movie.
It's a movie about racist,
but the movie itself is not racist.
Okay.
It's about race relations. Right. My
out of my fucking mind here. That.
What's that fucking one of the original
Hollywood movies where they have white
dudes dressed up in black face and then
make it black people look stupid and
that is the message of the movie.
They're not, they're not doing a movie.
They're making fun of white people who
do that or talking about white people who
do that. They are. That is
the message of the movie.
Yeah,
that black people are stupid.
That is a fucking racist movie.
See the difference?
What the fuck is the name of that movie?
Did you begin with an h? I have no
fucking stop talking on my cell phone.
I'm getting, you know what I'm not
doing. I'm fuck my cell phone. That's it.
It's over.
All right.
The fuck is the name of that movie.
All right. Forget it. Forget it.
I fucking give up.
I have to fucking,
I got to look it up now guys, this is
something, if you can hear it, my voice,
this is actually something that's fucking
scare in me is that I'm starting to
lose my God damn memory.
Somebody actually made a
the fuck is it?
Okay now
you know what,
with a fuck is it?
Yeah,
I really should edit all this out,
but I'm not going to do it.
I'm not going to do it.
Okay.
Why am I saying everything twice?
You know why?
Because I'm trying to find something
that somebody sent me. Okay.
Okay.
They sent me a nice little MP3 remix of
the thing and I had it all queued up and
I can't fucking find it.
You fucking asshole bill.
You really are an asshole.
You fucking worthless.
And this is why you have to fly out to
fucking Omaha at some point and tell some
jokes.
You know what I had last week,
I made fun of Omaha saying how I
wasn't going to do a show in Omaha.
And people were like, you know,
I said eventually I would do one,
but I was making fun of how many fucking
airplanes I would have to take to get
there. And I got like five
emails from people. Actually,
there's a direct flight from
fucking Gig or Duke or do you?
You're gonna land in a fucking cornfield
and you can just say it up fucking
stage right? But in their bill,
people in Omaha don't talk like that.
I don't give a shit. I know
they don't. Johnny Carson
was from Nebraska, wasn't he?
All I even remember about Nebraska was
doing college gigs out there and you
drive halfway across the state
in, in, in you driving across 80,
which goes the length of this, uh, east
west. Here's something that truckers know.
Do you guys know this shit? You know, if
you're on an, an even numbered highway,
that means it goes east,
west. And if you're on a odd
one, that means it's north.
South. Did you know that? Huh?
I'm talking about highways.
So don't even hit me with though.
We'll route one goes away. Shut
up. Not talking about roots.
I'm talking about highways isn't
another thing. If you're on,
if you're on a highway,
right?
Let's just say it's 95 and you
don't have a map all right in your,
and you see all of a sudden
there's a four 95 or eight to 95.
What that means is you are coming towards
a congested area and if it's during
rush hour,
you can jump on the two 95 of the four
95 and it will basically eventually re
hookup with the highway.
You're on 95 when you can avoid
the traffic and not add to it.
They did that one truckers.
Um,
it's like an la the four or five you got
the five goes right through the heart
of La, the four oh five when it
goes out around Santa Monica.
But there's so many fucking people,
it doesn't make a difference out here
cause they're all jammed. All right?
That's how much I know this fuck.
That's how much road work I've done.
So you get on the fucking 80 and you
get about halfway across Nebraska.
And if you're like me,
you're doing a college gig in
the middle of the winter time.
So all the crops are cut down.
All right?
And you can't tell where the
fucking dirt ends in the sky begins.
It's just all fucking gray.
And all of a sudden out of nowhere there's
like this wooden bridge footbridge or
some native American Indian shit.
You know, I just, you know, many
times I drove underneath that,
I don't know what the fuck it is racing
back to either flying out of Lincoln or
Omaha trying to get back to catch my
early flight and I would literally be
driving like a maniac and I be looking
out to the right and there would
literally be like a
flock of geese in that V,
that v formation. You know the one
that daffy duck was like, fuck this.
I'm not going snow flies. Don't
bother me. You remember that one?
I'd be seeing that shit.
I drove 80 I believe I drove 80 in
Wyoming and I saw a kind of antelope,
I don't even know what the fuck it was.
I had no idea what the fuck it was.
Just saw like species of animals that I
didn't even know fucking existed in this
country.
70 I remember 70 I've drove.
I've driven that one all the way from
la all the way right into New York City.
You get it all the way to about Jersey
and then you've got to fucking switch it
up. It's fucking brutal.
Ben, on all of them,
90 95
I think.
What is 35 go from Houston right
up to Dallas in the fucking insane.
Then all of a sudden, the years later I'd
be up in IB in, in like Iowa gone out.
It's just the same fucking highway and
you take from fucking Houston to Dallas
and it goes right up the
heart of this fucking country.
Isn't that fucking interesting? Um, yeah.
A lot of fucking roadwork.
I was supposed to be searching for
the email and actually just lean back
thinking about those fucking
days being out, you know,
many times I did Coosbay Oregon I
think like three or four fucking times.
Every time I went down there that God
damn seals whenever out they had this
thing where you could actually
see the seals sunning themselves,
which was fucking amazing to me at
that point because I lived on the,
I lived on the east coast,
you know,
when the fuck do you get a chance to
see that? You know, I just cannot,
I cannot find this fucking thing. I
have to find you. This, this clip,
this person send this MP three
he did a remix to a song.
I'm trying to kill time because I
can't fucking find it. Hey Bill.
Hey Bill. Go Fuck Yourself.
Read this. She can't.
This is what, these are the emails
I get from you guys. That's not it.
File recommendation,
Shithead Bar, fight story.
Uh, it's a, it's a mission. Now
give me something else to talk about.
You got anything? Any questions?
This is when I, it, it kills
me that I, that I don't,
I don't have any callers because
this is what the fuck happened.
I'm quitting after two more
emails I have, you know, it's not,
I'm going to be worth it by the
time I find it isn't the payoff.
It's not going to be worth it.
Hey, did the Phillies win tonight?
Please tell me they won. I've never given
a fuck about the Phillies until now.
I just can't stomach the fucking Lakers
and the Yankees are going to win it this
year.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Jesus Christ. To fucking Yankees.
What a team, Huh? What a fucking team.
What a fucking team. A Rod,
Rodney third [inaudible].
Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ coming up to the plate
and the Yankee sign him for one year.
They actually, uh, they
actually is suspended there.
No facial hair rule with him.
Johnny Damon's a little upset,
but you know he is the
son of God fucking cunt.
You fucking rich. Cons. He called that an
accomplishment. You win a world series.
What? Cause you got the most
fucking money. There's no,
there's no skill in that.
There's no fucking skill in that.
You fucking pieces of shit and
they actually have, you know what?
I can't stand about Yankee fans.
They actually had the nerve to be nervous
during the playoffs when they cut to
the crowd and like, oh Geez, I hope
this hundred million guy can do it.
If he doesn't do it, maybe to share
her, we'll deal with you fucking cunt.
You know, I hit about the fucking Yankees.
Whoever beats them the year before,
whoever their best guy
is within two years,
he's on the team to share a beat them
last year with the fucking angels.
Now he's on playing first base.
I've already bitched about this shit.
Who gives a fuck? Right?
It's just fucking baseball.
You know what I've been actually doing,
I've been watching the NHL network.
I actually just watched something about
the 1979 Montreal Canadians winning the
Stanley Cup.
You know what the worst thing about
watching the kid and he's winning the
Stanley Cup back then,
is you knew that there was going to be
some sort of heartbreaking Boston Bruins
loss and 79 I was too
young to remember it,
but I just remember
people bitching about it.
We basically beat the
Canadians for games to three.
And then with like a minute left,
they called too many men on the ice,
which is basically,
uh,
I'm trying to think of the
fucking, it's, it's, you know,
like in football when somebody a kicks,
because somebody calls for a fair catch
and you've got to give like five yards,
you gotta give the guy five yards.
So he can catch it and I, you know,
people break it all the time.
They never call it if the other defensive
player gets in face that that's like
calling,
making that call with one minute left
to decide who goes to the Stanley Cup
finals.
And then the fucking flying French Fox
ended up scoring a goal and then they got
the overtime goal. It was just fucking
annoying. It was annoying to watch,
but they did beat the rangers.
So that made me feel good. Um,
I think that's it guys.
I can't find this fucking thing.
This guy did a remix of that song, uh,
that, that, that data bup, bup, bup,
bup, Berlin heart, heart hat.
He did a remix of that. Me
saying [inaudible] can't,
can't and I thought it was
cute and I just, I, for me,
I can't find it. What was better? The fact
I just sang it for you was that decent.
All right. I give up. That's it. Jesus
Christ. What a fucking horrific podcasts.
But you know what? I did get it
out Monday morning. You know what?
I want to thank everybody.
I am.
We've been getting a ton of emails about
people got a letter from a postman who
just walks around listening to my podcast
as he delivers the mail laughing like
a maniac.
That's what everybody keeps telling me.
They keep listening to them when they're
supposed to be doing their job and
they're just sitting there laughing
like a fucking maniac. So why?
I know this one was a little fucked up.
The volume was messed up,
but that's what you get.
That's what she get.
Somebody sent me an email going
like, you know what? I'm so pissed.
I've been listening to Opie and Anthony
for awhile and I had no idea that you a
podcast. What the fuck? This
is what he said. He said,
I've been a fan for several years.
Uh, duty. Your appearances on the OPN,
Anthony show a being the
lazy shitbag than I am.
I've never checked out your
website until a week ago.
How has the podcast not mentioned
on Opie and Anthony? They actually,
they have mentioned it, but he said,
do they forbid that or something? No,
they do not. But he said, I guess
it's none of my business anyway,
but I'm pisses me off. You've been
doing it this long, two plus years,
and now I'm just finding out about it.
I've already listened to the last three
months of podcast and we'll continue
back until I've heard
them all. Um, you're,
you're a really funny guy and it's a
shame this podcast is flying under the
radar. Well, I say this to you. It is not
a shame that it's flying under the radar.
I liked that. It is, I don't hype it.
You find it, you find it. If you don't,
it's like fight club. Right. Except
you don't have to be a bad ass.
First rule about the podcast is not
that you don't talk about it. All right.
You know what the first rule is? Is that
you don't take the podcast seriously.
That's what it is.
Like this fucking guy tore me a new
asshole about rugby because I was shitting
on rugby. This fucking guy sends me
this whole, we are a few weeks ago,
he made some disparaging remarks about
rugby is compared to American football.
Every stop to think about how look
illogical and ludicrous it is to call it
football when you don't use your food.
He's giving me like Jerry Seinfeld Shit.
If memory serves,
you said something to the effect that
those rugby pussies would be getting,
wouldn't be getting up if ray Lewis
put a hit on him. You know what dude,
I stand by that statement, but
uh, I know I already you email,
but for all you fucking limey cuts
over there and fucking England.
The reason why shit on rugby was because
the English cont who wrote me was
shitting all over a
fucking American sports.
So obviously you're not
gonna treat me with respect.
I'm going to make fun of fucking
rugby and your little booty short,
Larry Bird short shorts from
the 19 fucking eighties,
and how every fucking 10 minutes. You
have to basically stick your head up some,
uh,
somebody else's ass as you guys tried
to do that elephant trick of kicking the
ball out the back. Totally respect rugby.
I think it's a fucking awesome game.
I've seen it on TV. It is the shit
and they have literally bone jarring.
Lose your filling fucking hits all the
time. I do think it's a great sport.
I do think people are tough,
but you know,
if you're going to shit
on American football,
I'm going to shit all over your sports.
That's how it works.
Please do not take the podcast seriously.
I don't fucking read.
I do it by myself. As you can tell what
the different levels of volume this week,
I'm not organized. All right? So that's
the one and only rule. All right.
Don't take it seriously. And if you can
remember, tell somebody in if not, don't,
because I think the smaller
this thing stays the cooler,
it's going to be named one fucking
thing that has blown up and,
and stayed at the same level of
quality. It doesn't, it doesn't,
you know, you want, I want it to
be like this. I want to fucking,
I'm gonna be down in the
Fox hole. You know, if I,
if I had this thing actually ever
fucking blew up and I'm, and I'm,
and I'm doing rants about
saying unacceptable, then
these fucking other cons.
We'll figure out that. That's what
we're saying. We're saying unacceptable.
Then the whole game plan is over and then
what I'm doing here is fucking useless.
Right.
Wow.
Did I just go off in a fantasy there where
this thing became the biggest fucking
radio show ever? I think
I just did. You know,
that's what happens when
you sit here by yourself.
You'll let your dreams leak out and
then people make funny and then you feel
silly. Um, all right. That's
the podcast for this week.
That was a fucking mess.
All right.
It was a fucking mess.
I'm going to, you know,
I think it kinda got back on the rails
afterwards, but it was a mess. You guys,
if we were on ESPN first came out and
they should sell those fucking rednecks,
they'd race in the mood. Remember that
they turned their tractors into these, uh,
I dunno what the fuck they were,
but they would,
they would race through the mugged.
You'd get bogged down.
That's what the fuck it was.
I was at redneck sitting
in that tractor in the mud.
I like how I had to explain that. It
sucked. Like he didn't fucking notice.
That's it.
All you guys have a great fucking week.
And um, that's it. That's the
podcast for this week. And I've,
uh,
talked myself into a corner once again
because I usually end with have a great
week.
That's what I usually say.
And then I continue talking and now here
I am down in the fucking murder again.
Um, hey, has anybody seen that
come? I'm sorry to keep talking.
If you guys seen that commercial
where they got the fucking, uh,
they're trying to help you out
of that financial, you know,
all these people in financial
difficulties. Um, AH, fuck.
That's what I was going to talk about.
God dammit.
No one's listening at this point. I'm
going to, I'm going to waste this story.
I went to the supermarket.
Okay.
And I don't wanna I don't use those
little savy save cards that they have.
Do you ever a little savvy saved card? And
I always say no. Would you like one? No,
I wouldn't.
Okay.
You know, because basically what
you're doing as a free fucking survey,
remember that shit so they can figure
it out. What you can't live without.
So they can jack up the price of that
food and then give you like nickel off of
like their version of corn
flakes. So I went in there, okay.
And they asked me if I had to sit in
their little safe card and I said no.
And he said, do you want one? I said,
no. And The lady goes, it's okay,
I'll just punch in a code anyways.
So she punches in a code
and I get money off anyways.
So it's like they even figured out a way
to figure out what I'm fucking buying
even when I'm saying go fuck
yourself to the safe thing.
So I think the only way to
get around it at this point,
I'm going to try it next time is I'm
going to walk in with cash and just have
cash and see what the fuck they do.
You know, they did it to me today,
it may see.
So I went out there and I bought some
towels and I bought some beer glasses.
That's what I bought Macy's. And they say,
do you ever, do you have a Macy's card?
I said, no, I don't. We'll
give you 25% off every douchey
thing you bought. I said,
that's okay. And she goes, it's all
right. I'll give you the discount anyways.
And she types in this fucking code.
Yeah,
I dunno what they're up to.
I really don't know what they're up to,
but I know they don't sit around
trying to make less money.
Does anybody know what
the fuck that's about?
That is your homework for this week.
If you still listened,
if you listened this far,
you fucking hate your job and you
need to get a new one. All right?
Don't hurt anybody at work. All right,
that's it. Now I'm done. Everyone.
You have a good week.
I'll talk to you next week.
Ooh.
Oh.
[inaudible].